hey uh real quick let me ask you do  who's your top five favorite rappers uh  controversial question no i usually  narrow it to a three but i could go five  um so at the the pinnacle you know and  it could go in any order for me but  realistically it should be krs-1 at the  top for me  um eminem  jay-z  rock kim  um coogie wrap  and uh you know i did i did a track with  cool g rap  one of the sickest in the world man and  stevo yeah  he said well i'm not gonna say you're  the next jay-z  oh my god yeah that's great so those  yeah those are my guys right there man  it's called stevo's hot sauce for your  butthole and if you go on amazon and  type in stevo's hot sauce for your  butthole and order yourself a bottle  you'd be really helping me because right  now we're ranked number 30 on all of  amazon and if you buy a bottle we might  go up the ladder and that would mean a  lot so please get on amazon and buy  stevo's hot sauce for your butthole  yeah  yeah dude